I want to talk a little bit about your
cuties Hank Jr is already a teenager
he's 13. Elijah is nine you know they're
building their own little lives and
we're so excited one is dunking it in
basketball at 13 years old he's 6'1 my
daughter is starring in the play Matilda
it's a really hard thing to manage when
I'm a public person raising two kids I
made a choice to put them on the show
for a second this season but I think
it's time to remove them really so you
don't want to show them moving forward
they didn't choose it you know so I'm
starting it's a that's a part of the
process too for me to remember that I
think that making sure that their lives
are good is number one they played a
little part in my show the seed this
season on Kendra sales Hollywood we
talked a little bit about my dating life
yes I think it's so really sweet of you
that you include them in these
conversations about your personal life
because ultimately it does impact them
how much do you consult them about you
know your potential dates or or where
your love life might be I experimented
with dating for like one second after my
divorce and it just didn't really sit
well with me it's not a good fit like I
don't want some random dude in my in my
house you know with my kid like it's
just weird so I'm like I don't think
this is gonna work so I
you know is love real probably but I
mean that person's gonna have to really
love two kids too and take them in like
their own his own children so I just
don't think that dating is in my future
or near future because my kids come
first at all times
and I put all of my focus love and
energy into my two kids
so I don't really have any left for like
some dude
I I mean I completely respect whatever
you want to do and what works for your
life but you are the ultimate catch
Kendra and I truly think you deserve
love and you deserve to have it a second
time is that not a priority at all for
you no dating whatsoever there's zero
priority to date right now I am in a
place where I'm building my new career
I'm building my new business and this is
the first time in my entire life where
I'm putting myself first
and
I used to put men above me
sexually and
but now finally for the first time in my
life
I'm getting my chance to to build my new
career I've never had that chance before
this is it
and this is for me and my kids so what
is what is dating gonna do so you don't
miss that companionship my kids have the
best father that's all that matters us
women we really do have to focus on
getting into those doors we really do
for our daughters and look I'm I'm not
perfect you know of course I look I'm
like oh my God but to fall in love right
now in the beginning stages of my career
not for you not a chance
I love how in a world where people can
be vicious exes you talk so glowingly
about Hank on the show how he is your
number one motivator he's like Kendra go
sell that house you know super
motivating super encouraging things
weren't always so peachy how did you
guys get to this beautiful place it just
takes two people putting their kids
first and being good period you know
the more you give the more you get and
the more you love the more things are
going to be better there's no hate at
all and there's no hate in my past so I
move forward and my goal is to sell this
house in Los Feliz for eight million
dollars my house I'm gonna sell that's
just not the second house
I've got my spot oh my God okay I got a
listing
now I've got to earn it Kendra sells
Hollywood season two you had so much fun
doing season one you were like let's go
I want more of this how is this season
different whoo season one is definitely
different than season two the season one
you know it was breaking into real
estate getting to know everyone you know
I was able to kind of make mistakes and
get away with it but now set season two
I'm actually officially in the real
estate game
so it's a whole different ball game I'm
still a single mom it's a lot of
pressure it's a lot of pressure to start
a new career with the world watching
it's a lot it is a lot we see you go
through a lot in season two how do you
describe what we're gonna see oh season
two is it can get heavy it's heavy it's
emotional it's
funny
um there's a lot that that happens I'm
some Playboy girl forever desperate for
fame wanting to sell a house
story at what point am I going to be
good enough I'm not I haven't made a
dollar I'm struggling really bad it's
really hard being a single mom and alone
starting a new career how scary is that
really really scary I love doing TV I
love being a single mom I love real
estate but sometimes when you know it
just gets to be a lot a lot of pressure
because you know I'm not a perfect
person I have a past I have two kids to
take care of on my own Financial person
in my life I don't have a nanny I don't
have housekeeping that's a lot for one
person to juggle all at once but
I know I'm strong enough to do it I have
dreams I have ambition I have
so much to to reach and I'm not going to
stop one of the things we love about you
is that you're just so open and honest
about all topics and when you were
sitting with Crystal Hefner you talked
about how you want to reverse some of
your plastic surgery where are you at in
that journey and why do you want to do
that Crystal Hefner comes on my show and
we have a good
eye to eye we have a good talk about
life you know we're talking about
plastic surgery and she was going in to
talk about how she removed her breast
implants and it's funny because I've
been thinking about doing the same thing
for many reasons you know for Health
number one for two times have changed
for my for me I'm not really like hey
boys as you can tell we're covered up
now boobs we're in for a while
and you know the trend is completely
changed it was the thing back then it
you know I got my boobs and I was like
oh my God fit right fit in you know and
then now I don't really care so much I
really truly want to focus on my health
my mental health I'm not really into
impressing boys anymore sure so things
have changed so we can get these guys
off my body right now is that like when
I get my next sale I'm going to treat
myself to this yeah and then have you
heard of this vagina tightening stuff
yes I have
oh my God what do you think of it like
what
40 Grand to just stitch up your like
what the hell
I might
I'm not thinking about it don't worry
laughs
[Music]